[Musik]
wie wird das wetter morgen in einer
woche oder in einem halben jahr ist es
wirklich so schwer eine langfristige
prognose zu erstellen
nein behaupten einige und sie wissen
wovon sie sprechen
[Musik]
der rat martin aus roten turm der nennen
george von der donner heinz aus
stechelberg der zurbuchen herrmann aus
unteriberg und der ragaz markus von ober
helfen spiele allesamt wetterpropheten
doch wie schaffen sie es schon wochen im
voraus zu sagen ob es regnet schneit
oder die sonne scheint wie kommen sie zu
ihren prognosen
helfen wir uns an ihre fersen und
blenden zurück in den august 2007 im
september noch wird der schnee um
weihnacht hoch wir treffen den horat
martin
seit zwei jahrzehnten ist er ein
mitglied der legendären muotathaler
wetterschmöcker den sommer verbringt er
als rinderwirt hoch über roten turm
kanton schwyz
im spätsommer sucht der 63-jährige nach
zeichen für seine winterprognose er
verrät nicht gerne wonach er sucht
dennoch griffen ihn begleiten
erste station ein sogenanntes prüffeld
landläufig alpen erika genannt
neben pflanzen würden ihm auch tiere
anzeigen wie das wetter wird meint
martin und führt uns an einen speziellen
ort
ich hatte zwar eine blasse dessen
scheiben hast du ja recht bekommt gibt
strenge setzte mit einer richtig räte
mit der suchseite der schutz zum buch
schuster mit diesen tricks der
nichtzahlung großdemos sieht das nicht
dass sie abhängig sind
das messer wie vor für den 7
sie sagen immer sie ständig mit zwei mal
sagen
doch ist das nützlich manche opfer kaum
zu wenn man drinnen ist der stoff eine
richtige diagnose wo die zeichen zweier
hunde so machen muss den indischen ozean
und das machen wir aber hinter gar
der sehr stark vertreten sagt richtig
wieder einig und gestochen scharfen
geschmacks dass ich es zeigen ich habe
mehrmals gesehen dass man irgendwo
prozent ausfindig machen
wer glaubt nur in der innerschweiz gäbe
ist wetterschmöcker der irrt der
walliser schnellen georges sammelt seit
über 30 jahren wetterdaten auch seine
methoden zur wette bestimmung liegen
abseits gängiger barometer klischees er
führt uns zu einer der galerien auf der
simplon pass straße wichtige station war
nicht bestimmen schnell dass dahinter
und je mehr wasser das der vlis vor
allem jetzt und ihr temperaturen sind
umso schneller durch das wasser
gefrieren und sobald wenn da ich bleche
instanz sitzt verarbeiten diese jetzt
ist der winter die mamas
[Musik]
einer wie der nellen braucht also keinen
dieser wetter satelliten um das wetter
zu bestimmen er registriert die kleinen
veränderungen der natur
[Musik]
genre schnellen und das wetter eine
jahrzehnte lange liaison seit 1975
notierte er es täglich und akribisch und
verfügt damit über eine immense
datenbank hinter den nüchternen zahlen
fand ihr ein muster bestätigt dass so
ein der hundertjährige kalender anwendet
den sieben jahres zyklus kollegen was
denn passiert ist und haben aufgrund von
einer hübsch rittner dort nach erlangen
sie prognose macht und haben sich zum
spezialist verlangen sie prognose
entwickelt wo vielfach richtig sind sie
und das entspricht nicht irgendwelche
laune oder dem zufall sondern ich glaube
dass die berechnung auf dem seeweg los
einfach erstaunlich sind dank dieser
statistik traut sich nennen schon jetzt
eine winterprognose zu
der winter ist 208 der ist 20 ist das
maßgebende jahr noch über installieren
in skoda 92 87
und wenn ich die zahlen hinter
kontrolliert hatte und ich genau wie das
verläuft wird mit einer strengen winter
rechne mit einer länger winter unter
strenger winter drauf steht ist das
fantasy viel schnee viel niederschlag
und auf trainer sieht da ist ein protour
[Musik]
das lauterbrunnental im berner oberland
die heimat des brunner heinz der 71
jährige kennt hier jeden berg und jede
alb kein wunder war er doch
jahrzehntelang hüttenwart jeep patriot
und bergführer seine passion ist die
jagd und das wild zeigt ihm an wie sich
das wetter entwickelt wird erfahrung
statt technik hier oben ein probates
mittel
deshalb wagt heinz bereits eine prognose
[Musik]
die tierwelt sagen dass das nicht
unbedingt können von mehr dicht dass sie
haben einfach das kilo krabben und ich
habe das gefühl das jahr danach lief er
reagiert und event rumänischer student
die november gewählten im netz ist damit
auch dass zwanziger schnafel einzel so
ist jetzt aloha he was er in bamberg
nicht das mit
ist oktober warm und fein kommt ein
starker wind rein
[Musik]
ein holzschnitzer in seinem element der
zurbuchen herrmann aus unteriberg kanton
schwyz ist nicht nur ein naturmensch er
hat auch mit einem naturprodukt zu tun
wenn man das schafft dass man noch den
unglaubliche konzentration und den ist
inzwischen vor einigen jahren zog der
gebürtige berner oberländer mit seiner
frau aus dem zitiert hierher
ihm sind die menschen der werke einfach
vertrauter mentalität axel karge
landschaft kg kg und die damen sind dass
sie halt im vertrag das lied für
geklebte neben der autor schnaps zwei
anstalten spritze
danke das ist das ist nur die spitze
[Musik]
das wetter schauspiel in den bergen
verfolgt er mit dem blick des scanners
[Musik]
den zeichen des vor winters will ja
nicht so recht trauen
sowohl inter sowie extreme albert schmid
und durch die höhere man doch schon in
denen die maschine automatisch weg war
und ich denke es wird vermutlich im
frühjahr werden wir meine seite besucher
für die tourismus dank nicht so leicht
ein ganz wilder auch wenn man es ihm
nicht sofort ansehen würde ist der ragaz
markus aus dem toggenburg kanton st
gallen
an normalen tagen ist der betriebsleiter
der bachelor badeanlagen da hat er auch
alle hände voll zu tun
doch in seinem innern ist der 43 jährige
von einem virus infiziert das stets
wütet das wind virus so oft es geht und
nicht selten in begleitung seines sohnes
florian macht sich der winter auf den
weg zu seiner wetterstation
der weg führt sie durch die halbe
schweiz ins oberalp gotthardmassiv
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jedes mal wenn der ruf aussage davon
fährt sei ruhig sitzen im auto
sie werden geschlossen werden offene
videos und das einfach einmalig
die wetterstation entpuppt sich als
ehemaliges wachhäuschen einer
militärischen festung
noch vor wenigen jahren hätte man sich
hier gar nicht aufhalten dürfen
heute gehört der ausblick wieder allen
[Musik]
jetzt heißt es vorwärts machen nachdem
einheizen kann sich markus ragaz wind
und wetter zu wenden
sein ganzes treiben ist letztlich einem
ziel unterworfen ist natürlich sch
windig kite also der rektor auf den ball
aber nicht am interviewten zeigen hätte
ich an 200 witze stunde kann der dem und
dem mars zwingli passt zum beispiel den
strom kriege dann ist das einfach
überzeugung begann das rennen mit 2 und
geschafft dass das uba das das widerrufs
stark und mit den relevanten helm auf
dem kopf und schutz genommen das ist hat
auch die faszination an gewitter spendet
aber es behindert das ist glücklich er
liegt auf der hand
es liegt in der natur der sache dass ein
von die bei diesem panorama gleich
doppelt so gut schmeckt
der hohe rat martin mutter thaler
wetterschmöcker ist im wahren leben
verkäufer von landwirtschaftlichen
artikeln
speziell bekannt ist er als händler von
hochwertigen sensen
[Musik]
er reist viel herum um seine kunden zu
besuchen
klar dass sie auf diese weise so manches
hört und sieht wo er hinkommt ist das
wetter ein hauptthema auch bei ebnöther
melchior dauer im schweizerischen
forderte nach dem strengen winter hin
oder her
eigentlich ist martin ja gekommen um
eine sense zu verkaufen
schon bald es der handel perfekt
so sind alle zufrieden
der ebnöther melchior hat ein neues werk
zurück und der hohe rat martin wieder
ein weiteres puzzleteilchen für seine
prognose ein neuer tag auf der
wetterstation bei markus ragaz die
ehemalige militär festung auf 2200
metern liegt auf einer klassischen
wetter scheidl
die station ist bei jedem wetter
exponiert ein idealer ort um
windmessungen zu machen den winter zu
bestimmen und die stürme voraus zu sehen
mir ist ganz richtig als mod land die
kassen ab glaubt das sind die
atlantischer tiefs zu hoch der druck der
gesetz das ist hochinteressant wie fluss
den winter beobachtet auch bestand dem
tour richtig norden moskaus land auch
mit mehr dem natur und das alles gibt
für mich das bild und die bezieht würde
jetzt integrität also den ernst mäßige
temperaturen mild abschließt
das schließt aber halbrunden kaltluft
üblich nicht aus aber ein eher milden
winter niederschlags mäßig wird die sage
er drückt also für alle skigebiete sind
wird das bedeutet und richtig lange
halten die hält die über das wird hier
ein lustiger winter im doppel bord und
in der tat gebiet wird er wählt im
wallis wird es sehr kalt und in
rotenturm und im berner oberland soll es
vor allem vor weihnachten stark schneien
kann es sein dass wirklich alle
wetterpropheten gleichzeitig recht haben
[Musik]
besucht beim roten turm adolf archivar
albert martin
hier sammelt wetterschmöcker martin
horat weitere indizien für seine
winterprognose alte chroniken und
zeitungsartikel aus früheren
jahrhunderten werfen ein interessantes
licht auf längst vergangene
wetterphänomene
für martin ist klar die schwankungen der
letzten winter sind nicht
außergewöhnlich
das bestärkte ihn in seiner
ursprünglichen vermutung bricht
[Musik]
action wie in einem agentenfilm im
hinteren lauterbrunnental berner
oberland und alles nur für ein
schindeldach auf eine alp doch der
brunner heinz der spült was für ein
winter kommt
er hatte seit ich hier auf 1600 metern
kann der winter jeden tag einbrechen
[Musik]
diese alphütte ist für den 71-jährigen
seit langem ein fixpunkt in seinem leben
schon als bub hat ihr hiergeist weiden
lassen
die klimaerwärmung hat er hautnah
miterlebt
und da ist der gletscher sketche denn
dieser mensch erzeugt ist wiederum dann
als zweiter und sie fällt wenn der
schneefall oft vom fell seiner paket
also das große stücke startplätze dort
zurückgegangen
als würde der gletscher ein
ausrufezeichen setzen gibt er gleich
selber einen kommentar ab
dennoch vertraut heinz auf die kräfte
der natur hat eine schlechte wende hin
recht das ist schon ein anderer so
makaber vorjahres hat der park auftreten
wenn im herbst der vom schwarz ziel und
hat sich doch ziemlich um hessen enden
[Musik]
fürs dach bleiben den gelernten
zimmermann und seinen kollegen also nur
noch wenige tage in rotenturm naht der
entscheidende moment nach dem hochrad
schreibt seine winterprognose nieder
der dezember steht schon bald fest
tja das mit dem blocher war dann auch
eine art klimakatastrophe aber eben eine
andere stellt sich die frage wie martin
sein eigenes wetter talent entdeckt hat
[Musik]
gelernt sein
auffällig ist martin hat viele fans vor
allem beim weiblichen publikum
die mögen ihn und er mag sie dennoch als
wetterpropheten kommen frauen für ihn
nicht in frage
die frauen stehen knietief
diese frau nimmt im großen und ganzen
nichts war für mich dass ich es mal
einen wert von frauen und die kriterien
draht zwischen system und das sind die
teams 2 2 1 weltmeister
zurück ins wallis die brasserie
wallisern in zion genre schnellen
besucht seinen ehemaligen arbeitsort
hier begann seine vita karriere wenn
allen damals in den siebziger jahren ein
sonniges wochenende voraus sagte füllte
man hier in der ehemaligen abfüller mehr
bier ab so einfach war das
prognose probiert natürlich wenn ein
trick flogen meines natürlich falsch ist
sagt horst im klinikalltag sie
tourismuswirtschaft und sowas honeywell
aber ich habe mich verändern allem
köpfchen alle in bar sowie 4 ist deshalb
seine bürger so schönes geschirr zum vor
ist aber schon mehr sagen
im landtag ist als beraterin des
regentropfen
dann will uns georges an einen weiteren
ort führen wo das wetter noch wetter ist
[Musik]
zu mächtigen aletschgletscher nur wenige
meter über ihm prallen das atlantische
und das mediterrane wetter aufeinander
eine zweite station
hier kann man nämlich vieles vom waldsee
von opel ist etc alle situationen
snowtrex rhonetal rad und süd hat und
weil es hier so speziell ist treibt ist
in wallisellen in einen heiligen zorn
wenn esther schweizer das hiesige
wetterphänomen ungenau einschätzen von
schweizer fans oder bucher chef ist das
gerät einfach katastrophal ist gerade 30
prozent akzeptieren vor allem wenn es um
tages prognose des ins netz läuft aber
vor allem aber die langfristige die sind
unbrauchbar
und die müssen wir unbedingt versetzte
und zwar mit 2 in der zone i tele
ohne not das ist gebiert vom obergoms im
lötschental und volker bord denn das
eigentliche rhonetal das ganze tal
zwischen der walliser alpen und der
wagen rollte und der kommt aus süd
wartet das ist dann wieder als pintol
der simplonpass wie zermatt werden wir
das liegt alles auf der höhe von der
sinn von locarno bellinzona wieder
flogen bringen und das ist natürlich
absoluter doch nicht nur das ärgert ihn
auch die panikmache rund um die
gletscher rücken kann er schon gar nicht
mehr hören ich bin ein wenig weniger
eine rolle ist ein gravierender fall
läge so langweilig aber die pläne ich
sieht der hessische regelmäßig subjekt
aletsch gletscher ist schon viel
schlendert sie auch jetzt und ich wieder
vorgestoßen und jetzt ist natürlich
vollkommen sie lange zeit aber wir
starten periode ist sie wieder erholt
[Musik]
wieder mal ist soweit nach den beratern
der traditionellen herbstversammlung des
katholischen mit geologischen vereins in
der schweiz wie die berühmte mutter
thale wetterschmöcker richtig heißen die
sechs propheten füllen die größten
hallen wie in einem katholischen rand
sind die abläufe klar geregelt zuerst
folgt die ankündigung diesmal hat ein
anderer gewonnen
unser martin geht leer aus
nichtsdestotrotz gibt auch er seine
winterprognose abbrach mich selbst am
besten
februar bis circa meter schnee 15 mal
regen aber dann auch kaum 29
der schaut der kann ich nicht sagen wie
es aussieht punkte müsste mich zu vielen
strängen um einen hauch mehr zu
berechnen
und prompt war das auch keine starke
[Applaus]
nur wenige kilometer vom mattertal
entfernt tagen ende oktober auch die
briger wetterfrösche auch sie füllen
jeden platz im schlaflied zu untersberg
bei ihnen wirkt alles ein wenig rosiger
ihr präsident ist man staune der
zugewanderte hermann zu buchen
auch hier wird eine rangfolge erstellt
mit ihren trefferquote stehen die briger
den mutter talern um nichts nach umso
stolzer führt präsident hermann den
sieger
[Applaus]
die frosch eckpunkte 40 dass die sache
jetzt kommen hin blut sein
hat martini einen weißen bart wird der
winter lang und hart
[Musik]
tatsächlich wie viel unsere fünf
wetterpropheten vorausgesagt haben ist
der wintereinbruch früh und heftig
sturmjäger markus ragaz erlebt die ihn
auf seine weitere station ist noch nicht
fertig der sturm blieb blass zum rückzug
dort glauben dass ich wunderschön sich
wer streicheleinheit wiener wellness
cool dass ich einfacher bis wunderbar
aus und die fans extrem apathisch
vorarbeiterin rieskrater kita gefährlich
verweichlicht für den verweichlichten
körper der dementsprechende
daunenschlafsack den braucht auch denn
die hochsaison für einen sturmjäger ist
der winter und ragaz übernachtet gerne
ins biwak immer dabei das kernstück
jeder wind jagd als wichtigste vor allem
was der freiluft der jagd bis 225
stundenkilometer der chance gewaltig die
technischen und im rucksack um sie zu
schützen
auch wieder atmosphärische und tödlich
[Musik]
der winter entwickelt sich dank seiner
tiefdruckgebiete ideal ab dezember
locken die stürme und markus ragaz lässt
sich nicht zweimal bitten
[Musik]
für uns nimmt er die kamera mit und
dokumentiert seine diversen rau niehues
mit den kräftigen sturmtiefs
[Musik]
doch die orkan jagd birgt auch risiken
wie ein vater für mich in abstiegsgefahr
als für die größte risiko die werke
johann abstufung dankt idee canine
unterricht heißt ja so dankt blitz
entladen sind für die vier verbliebenen
us masters wieder der strom oder gas
muss stehen ist also als restrisiko bei
immer wieder rückte aus um
windgeschwindigkeiten über 100
kilometern pro stunde zu messen
höhepunkt seiner jagd das orkantief
kirsten sie tobt mit über 160 sachen
durch die berge und wirft den stärksten
sturm jäger um
a
ist januar hell und weiß wird der sommer
gerne heiß
[Musik]
wir treffen schnellen auf dem
simplonpass wie er vorausgesehen hat
liegen die südalpen und einer dicken
schneedecke wieder nimmt er uns mit zu
seinem wasserfall in einer der galerien
der passstrasse doch diesmal ist aus dem
gletscher bach eine durchgehende eiswand
geworden
[Musik]
wenn das so ist das dass ich bis zum
schluss gibt ob zusammenstellen ich
frage ist wohin das wasser bis er ist
das nichts anderes als läuft weiter und
starken wind letztere besonders sie als
jahr ist ein relativ warme januar xiii
wenn man waren bei früheren mittelteil
der talent froh dass sie als eine show
aber nicht ankommen und vor und prüft
sein pachtvertrag und es ist nichts auf
einen schwindler sei das gibt dem
strengen winter und ausgestattet mir das
jetzt ganz wichtig und das genau
feststellen
[Musik]
heimatliche gefühle im radiostudio hier
betreuten allen während jahren eine
wöchentliche wettersendung
seine meinung ist auch heute noch
gefragt und schwarz frühlingsanfang das
volk pc vorstellen zusammen konnte so
richtig wärme ich rate zum 23 aber mit
also dachte temperatur vorgemacht dass
ein sprecher im geht es mit einem 7
jahres sind die verlockende aussichten
also allen verspricht sommerliche
temperaturen an ostern nur kommt es auch
wirklich so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
pitts gloria padong das schilthorn auf
fast 3000 meter über meer
der berner oberländer heinz brunner
sieht seine winterprognose bestätigt es
herrschen ideale schneeverhältnisse über
1500 meter schon manchen winter hat der
ehemalige pisten patrouille hier erlebt
doch einer war wohl der aktien reichste
vor 40 jahren als erst an skifahrer für
james bond war eine majesty's secret
service george mason wie marc als bund
ein flop gewesen sein
doch für den stechen berger sind die
dreharbeiten mit ihm unvergesslich
[Musik]
erstmalig vorhaben das er hat meine der
abfahrt bei einer verfolgungsjagd james
bond ist fotos gerade hell madrid fahren
das hingegen ist ein trick sie
therapiezentrum james bau von ställen
scheinen gelernt amorbacher der eu
triebschnee aktien blieben stecken und
hat mir überschlagen ob in der hand dem
der berg sehen das natürlich die berge
sind für heinz geübte augen quasi ein
offenes buch um das wetter abzulesen
im gegensatz zu seinem walliser kollegen
allen glaubt er dass der winter science
zepter noch nicht aus der hand gibt ist
das okay im februar das gehirn noch
schmerzen das einfach unfair
[Musik]
wenn es im februar nicht schneit dann
schneit es in der osterzeit das rotem
turm am ohr am 21 februar 2008 vom
schnee den martin horat letzten herbst
prophezeit hatte sehen wir nicht mehr
viel liebe nicht so an
nichtsdestotrotz für martin ist der
winter noch lange nicht vorüber
das sieht der an dieser wirke und allein
durch die geschichte
es ist dann versucht unser
wetterschmöcker etwas ganz neues
anhand eine bohrung in einer
flussschleife humor will er eine
langzeitprognose wagen
[Musik]
es verwundert immer wieder was der boden
so alles hergibt der mitte februar hat
auch der niedrige hermann zurbuchen aus
dem atelier gelockt ihm genügt ein
kleiner spaziergang um zu wissen was er
von diesem monat halten soll
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute ist ein großer tag für herrmann in
der du es berghütte auf 1600 metern wird
er mit zwei kollegen ein konzert geben
die ausflugs ist restlos ausverkauft
damit wird klar dass der winter
hierzulande auch ein wirtschaftsfaktor
ist nicht das gemacht weil ich habe
dabei aber richtig gehört also mir das
so lang wie möglich kompakte schnee dass
wir nicht im wintersport freuen
das glück träumen und das tier biss kann
am abend geht die post ab das thema der
klimaerwärmung ist nur noch angesichts
der hitze in der beiz ein thema hermann
zu buchen und seine beiden kollegen
sorgen für stimmung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch den übrigen wetter frische gefehlt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die höhepunkt die obligate abfahrt auf
einem gammel eine art ski schlitten auch
herrmann lässt sich diesen spaß nicht
nehmen und führt seine frische ins tal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fürchte nicht den schnee im märz grund
das läuft ein warmes herz
[Musik]
da freut sich ein wetter prophet eine
dicke schneedecke hat sich über das
roten turm uhr gelegt
es wäre ja nicht der martin horat wenn
er nicht selbst den rauch der
tabakpfeife als meteorologisches
instrument nutzte trotz aller warnungen
tatsächlich der winter ist zurückgekehrt
und wie es ist ostern der erste
frühlingstag
während andere eiersuchen erstellt wind
jäger markus ragaz ein biwak auf dem
ganz hoch über dem toggenburg ein
atlantische tiefdruckgebiete ist
angesagt mit windgeschwindigkeiten von
über 150 kilometern pro stunde sind sie
oft dargestellt
ich könnte mir eigentlich alles trat auf
eine spitze für die stasi den abgang der
familie zuliebe sich aussteller wird man
möglich mit der oper blieben bei diesen
wetterverhältnissen an den frühling zu
denken bereitet leyen mühe nicht zu
einem wetterpropheten ragaz wagt den
blick nach vorne
werden diese geduld auf den ersten tag
und auch den ersten wochen sehr viel
schnee für die er wird dafür mit saus
und braus roll und zügige heitzer doch
zuerst müssen man und zählt die kommende
nacht überstehen
ein schneesturm die woche nach der
stürmischen nacht
wenn der april spektakel macht gibt's
korn und wein in voller pracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von allen seiten kommen sie her um sich
zum ersten mal zu treffen
der offizielle wetterbericht hat zwar
regen vorausgesagt unsere propheten
erwarten schönes wetter und tatsächlich
bald lacht die sonne nicht nur im glas
[Musik]
natürlich schwebt nur eine frage über
dem treffen wer hat während der letzten
monate die beste prognose gestellt
zur klärung dieser frage braucht seinen
unabhängigen schiedsrichter wer wäre
besser geeignet als der wette prophet
vom sf dach thomas bucheli
die überraschung gelingt den medien
hätten die fünf propheten als letzten
erwartet
[Musik]
umso gespannter erwarten sie sein urteil
die prognose dass ich wirklich recht
wenig wo wir hin zum teil popo
verblüffen die branche interessant finde
ich das eigentlich relativ viel brachte
felix hinterwirth für der schnee über 30
meter entspricht dem säbel jahreszyklus
das halten sie aber ich muss sagen ich
absolut zu getroffen mit denen
gratulation holte wo stets 22 grad als
natürlich ja das ist schon fahrlässig
sie kann ja nicht über monate ist da ein
wenig wärme bringt halt ist natürlich
nicht ganz so dass ich mein bein nicht
effektiv der winter kann meine derselben
natürlich die ganze statistik nach oben
drückt denn mit märz mit schnee
eigentlich dazu getroffen aber also
schon grundsätzlich zwar erhalten sie
martin horat strenge winter speziell der
hermann lang am fühlinger see wie ist
die oster markus tendenz war wie stark
die sturmfront muss ich sagen dass ich
also 200 studien jahren dazu geführt
dass ich absolut zutreffend das freut
mich sehr schwierig dagegen wir zeigen
dass die kinder ist und darum will ich
doch wieder einheiten
ein mildes urteil aus berufenem mund da
wollen wir natürlich erst recht wissen
wie der sommer 2008 wird
ich glaube dass mit profit es gibt es
für kroos einmal mehr ihren siegeszug im
winter absolut mit dem stärken und somit
ich mit der summe ein rasches und seiner
länge der war der sicheren sehen
es gibt für schlechtwettertage nicht
verschweigt wie möglich angebaut wird
sicherlich ein ganz normaler schönes und
anklam interzum ruiz verdienen
das wären 80 liter motor ist dass unsere
heizt dann heißer sommer und geht einige
wollten die prognosen gezahlt
übrigens männerwelt wissen wir zwar
europameisterschaft ist mir zu heftig
aber wir sehen uns ran frau kommt in der
meisterschaft um die seit dem ersten
spiel
[Musik]